WINGS, STARTS FOR GOAL TENDER
SINCE THOMAS GRIESE
ZADINA.
DANNY AND HOPE
THEY CAN GET GOING TONIGHT AND
GET TOTARASENKO HAD THE SHOULDEE
POWER PLAY.
>> ONCE THAT'S BROKEN UP, TOO
MANY GUYS LOOKING AT THE PUCK
AND NOT TRYING TO FIGURE  THE N.
>> RAY
>> YOU MAY BE STARVED FOR DINNER
FOR TYLER BERTUZZI.  THROUGHGH
KNOCKED AWAY AN FABBRI.   PAST
EIGHT GAMES.   MODERN DAY NHL.
>> VENMO.
>> HETIME.
>> THE PROBLEM WITH THEM ON THE
ROAD WAS IN SITUATIONS LIKE  JUS
EVENING.  .
>> LOOK AT THAT, HEAD AND DAVI
ANGLE.
>> IT AMAZING HOW HE CONTIAIN.
AND SAAD COULDN'T GET A SHOT.
SAAD,SHOT.
GOOD THIS IS AN INTERESTING
GOAL FOR ADAM ERNE AND THE RED
WINGS, HE HE'LL BEGIN A NEW
ONE TOMORROW NIGHT.
>>
LEAD PASS HERE THOUGH.
GAGNER WITH
BLUES TIED
PARAYKO.
DOWN LOW, O'REILLY, SAVE MADAD
SCHENN.
CUT OFF BY NEDELJKOVIC AND GIVE
THE
GOAL IN 13 GAMES.
I GUESS SO!
>> THAT'S THE SHOT YOU PRACTICE
EVERY TIME